So how does the inflammation tie into the mast cell?
Well, I didn't really think they were really tied in
until I had to do a presentation for Dr. Bob Miller.
Dr. Bob Miller does a lot with genetics.
And he asked me at his stand-up conference last year
to research the mast cell.
He's like, Kelly, I think there's something going on
with the mast cell.
I think we need to take a look at it.
I'm like, mast cell.
From my education, medical school and
astrophobic medical school,
I'm like, you know, that reminds me of like,
stuffy noses and stuff.
But I mean, my mind was blown.
This, this mast cell is so vitally important to the
inflammation cascade and I'm going to teach you why.
So first thing I do when I'm researching this mast cell,
I brought up this beautiful electronic prostate image of,
this is a vessel.
So these are the endothelial cells right here.
It's a parasite.
That's a red blood cell.
So that's a vessel.
This right here is the giant mast cell.
It's just waiting and watching with everything that's
flowing through your blood.
So it's just that gatekeeper.
And it's sitting there.
It's from the myeloid lineage.
So it has vesicles inside of it.
And for every vesicle, which usually they have about
from around 500, there's 50 chemical mediators that,
if it gets activated, it will spew out.
It will spew out and they go all over your body.
They have wide spread effects.
These do not move.
They just sit right there.
But there are mediators, what they're vomiting,
really can cause some downstream symptoms that
are ongoing and ongoing.
So really important also, because these mast cells
are most plentiful with where our body meets the environment.
They're plentiful in our gut.
They're plentiful in our hypothalamus.
So they're really keeping an eye on.
They're surveying our environment.
And we're going to talk about what can cause them to
degranulate as well.
So you can't read this.
And now I can't either.
I don't have this memorized.
But this right here is a list of the mediators, the things
that they will, when they're stimulated, what they're
going to put out in the bloodstream.
And a lot of them are nasty.
TNF alpha, IL1 beta, IL6 inflammatory inflammation
causing compounds.
And look on the physiological effects from some of these things.
That says histamine right there.
We all know histamine, what it does.
And these, I will say this, that the mediators, they're not bad.
It's not bad if you hit your thumb with a hammer for your
mast cells to go, oh my gosh, there's inflammation there.
And we have to bring in the cytokines.
We have to bring in, so we have the redness this one.
That's good.
But over and over every day for these mast cells to be degranulated
granulating, that can cause major problems, major symptom
patterns.
So what are the triggers for mast cells?
Well, you can be cut off in traffic and get really mad at
your significant other.
And via the corticord releasing hormone, that can actually
set it off.
So it's real.
It's like when someone gets old, man, they turn red.
Massol, massol.
It could be mold.
It can be a virus.
It can be heavy metals.
They all can stimulate that mast cell.
Stimulate the mast cell.
And then when you stimulate, you poke the bear too many times,
then you can just poke it a little bit.
And it still spews out.
And that's that mast cell disorder, where people just have the
tiniest triggers.
Some foods, things can just trigger them.
And then they can just have that explosion of symptoms.
So people say to me, well, the mast cell, my patient, you
kind of have to educate them a little bit further, because
they think, OK, the histamine, I get that.
But then I pull up this chart and have this chart laminated.
Because I said, this right here is one thing that your mast cell
just put it into your bloodstream.
Just one histamine.
And the downstream effects of that are so far fetched.
I had a lady, this is a CNS chronic migraines,
chronic, chronic, chronic.
I put her on some mast cell stabilizers.
We worked hard to get at the root cause.
She had a virus.
And her headaches went away.
So you know, you can do things to stabilize the mast cell.
But really, when you're looking at your patient, you're like,
I don't know who has mast cell.
I'm not sure.
You can kind of get an idea how there can be so many things.
There's trip taste that is a meat tenderizer.
And if that meat tenderizer is released in your brain,
your neural junctions, you're going to have brain fog,
memory issue is anger, a lot of different things
when they get triggered.
And this is after a theory, he is known
as the mast cell master.
And I like this quote from him.
It says, mast cells are known for their involvement
in allergic reactions.
Yes, we know that.
But we were the first to show that they
are also necessary to initiate inflammation.
Thus participating in inflammatory diseases
that worsen by stress, such as autism, cancer, chronic fatigue
syndrome, interstitial scitus, migraine, headaches,
psoriasis, and multiple sclerosis.
Who has patients who have things that are worsen by stress?
You might want to think about stabilizing their mast cell.
You might want to think about giving them
neutersuitables that have been shown in clinical trials
to stabilize them.
You can also use medications.
There are things that you can H1 and H2 blockers
that are over the corner.
But really, some of these compounds that Jason and I have
been working on throughout, they're very powerful
in stabilizing the situation, like getting a leg up.